for the episode this is the recruitment
rollercoaster podcast my name is Hisham
azuz and today I'm joined by Joe from
hunted hello
that's just how you're known isn't it
I'm handover from hunted that's it and
just to set the scene we're in the
hunted offices in a nice Thursday
evening yeah and we're gonna have a good
old chat about recruitment Jay yeah and
because obviously we all know if any of
you that do now Joey's is quite vocal
just a little bit yeah so as you know me
where I always like to start
how did Joe from hunted and to the
recruitment world mate how did Joe enter
the recruitment world cool so I suppose
it starts with I was a drama student at
uni so I graduated from Union realized
there was no jobs for drama students mmm
so then I went into a sales job got it
through a graduate recruitment agency
and in this office were in the shared
office block and I arranged a five size
every Tuesday for everyone in the office
block and as part of our office block
there was a rep track in there and after
about two years of doing sales for this
company I was chatting to them and they
said to me have you ever considered
recruitment because there's good money
in it and it's really like sales and I
says I haven't bought you know let's
have a chat so they got me out to a few
places interviewed it a few places and
then right at the end of it they offered
me as well they were the only thing
you'd be a really good fit for us so
yeah so I went and work for them chose
them over the other opportunities me
chose them well because I knew them
already and I'm quite football with him
quite a lot and I knew they were good
yeah I got on really well with them and
this is in Manchester this is in
Manchester yeah just on the outskirts of
Manchester within sure for anyone that
knows Manchester Ridge is a little bit
ropey is that yeah it's a bit what's
like obviously we're here in well where
we are is it what area is actually this
the hunters offices is like its bearing
the Vanden yeah yeah so see like when
you go out for lunch and ferrand and
there's pretty good choice like what
what we got there mate so and where we
were in winning short there was a chippy
chips yeah and
there was a place that the great jacket
potatoes oh my god and we charm the
ladies in there and they gave us extra
portions really nice decent and then
there was a good greg's of course and
there was a pound bakery as well which
is the hound Baker
yeah which the greg's knockoff yeah
great and then there was a big Asda as
well really that's it beaten
no avocados well now I've had as yeah
fair enough mate so what did you what
did you sell him before you went into
red throat I was selling IT data center
space really yeah how did that for how
long yeah two years really yeah glam
like just complete like beady like b2b
it was yeah it was a decent I wasn't
great really I don't really get any
training any support is a tiny tiny
company was that put in a room with
someone and was it just like cold cool
yeah a bit of that and then there was
like a bit leads and we had some good
partnerships and stuff and well yeah I
wasn't smash it was it there like deal
valued quite big look was it like big
yeah so there's some really big ticket
items it was like you could do a deal
could be he tore 10 grand a month
contract for 12 months really yeah
all right the smallest was about three
grand a month but for a 12-month minimum
so like I couldn't imagine the sales
process is pretty quite long yeah it
could be it could be no I just often
that's interesting because surely some
of that stuff helped you in this 100%
you know I mean yeah that's was
interested so just to frame up so join
that rhetoric firm how many of them was
there six okay so it's a small agency
yeah but for Rex reg that's a pretty
decent agency that is yeah but yeah yeah
not huge so and then how long was you
there for two years and we listened to
the day yeah and then after that and
then I moved to London and then is that
when you join no so I went and joined a
company called econ I gotta like digital
recruitment okay and I was there for
nine months really and then you done
hunting I'm gonna join how long have
been hunting uh two years two years yeah
okay yeah alright so let's go through
that okay so it's interesting in because
obviously obviously joined the rhetoric
and then like what was that whole
experience like there mate like that's
the two years there you just completely
immersed into
not just being a recruit about you being
a recruit the recruit for critters yeah
do you not I mean so I absolutely loved
it really and loved it I was working
with such a great team they're the guys
the guys and oh yeah I was gonna say
yeah they were superb every single one
of them loved them all yeah I had one of
the best managers that I've ever had
Ireland and the training I got there was
superb yeah and it was all about
building that relationship with people
really getting to know them going for a
beer with understanding what's most
important to them I'm taking you time
not feeling like you competing against
every other rhetoric out there that's
trying to ship them out to as many
places as possible
we were like get them out to three
places that you think are bangin got
really bad and and do that what was your
perception of recruitment then before
you sort of entered this world as you
were as you then got to know more about
the industry the people you're dealing
with stuff at that like what was your
perception before you did all that
if recruitment yeah yeah so it was like
long hours really it was like smashing
the phone and it was all about cool
times and you know that perception that
everyone's got a recruitment yeah I had
exactly the same really but I spoke to
someone who worked in recruitment they
were like it's not all like that and so
so what being a rhetoric yeah difficult
that in that it is yeah like a lot of
people just think they're like no way
like I would never do that sort of thing
you know I mean because like what so
recruiting recruiters and they just an
absolutely pain in the arse I mean the
can be yeah hmm so you say more so than
not I would say that I got a quite a
good relationship with the candidates I
worked with I was it experienced you
then yeah so my sweet spot was like and
people get into the second or third job
but they've got sort of 18 months
experience thinking about is this the
right company for me so people that have
sort of started in a big kpi environment
and wanted to go somewhere a little bit
more relaxed maybe mmm-hmm but I was all
about like my ratios there so people in
the business that were generating far
more candidates than me like way more
candidates than me but then they were
having a lot of people drop out because
for whatever reason and whereas I was
like how long we generate
for the candidates but I'll make sure my
ratios are really sweet mmm so I would
partner with some really good clients
that I trusted that I knew could run an
interview process that would be quick
that would not under offer that were
fair and I'd work with candidates that
would meet me and that would like sort
of prove that they were willing to
commit yeah and don't get me wrong there
was a lot of conversations on the go
about how sort of long ongoing
conversations about to help people but
once they were ready to go I'd sort of
properly vet them and win and then yeah
that's phantom what typically then just
just out of interest what was like the
most common frustration he saw in people
that are in that sort of period cuz I
reckon a lot of people listening will be
maybe in that period they might join the
big business and might join a smaller
business but probably a lot of people
listening are two years in freeze in
more experienced or less than that what
was like the typical frustration that
you saw that typically led people to be
like you know Joe I'm actually open to
see my houses out there was a lot of
quite common frustration that you ended
up always talking about that these
people how door yeah I think that a lot
of people wanted to move from sort of
like a really outgoing crazy drinking
culture type environment and go
somewhere a little bit more grown-up
when people that wanted to take the
careers a bit more seriously I mean
don't get me wrong there's nothing wrong
with that going out crazy environment if
that's what you're into
but there are a lot of people that go
and do that for two years go hard for
two years yeah and like actually you
know what I want I want a better
work-life balance or bit of flexibility
or whatever that is yeah that was quite
a big one or like a lack of progression
as well village because so many people
that are sticking good numbers on the
board hmm and then the lat okay I really
want to manage someone now I want to
have a resource or or whatever it is and
the company won't do it mmm because
they're making good money so yeah and
they know that their billions will
probably drop off a bit if I do that so
it's okay cool so it's typically those
sorts of things that people came to you
about okay and then um was gonna say so
what what have you before we go into
like the whole sort of recruitment
business I mean recruitment businesses
historically aren't great at cream for
their own businesses right yeah this is
mad
I didn't know I got a flavor of this and
because I I was in a small agency
outside of London and then when I moved
to London just got completely like into
the just sucked into this recruitment
wild in London and obviously which is
mental yeah and like that I really
recognized that early on when I was
meeting recruitment businesses and these
types of things that like literally
typically their biggest challenge was
hiring for their own business so we're
definitely gonna dive into that but I'd
love to get your thoughts in that sort
of two year period like what were some
of the sort of common things that you
saw in people that made them not really
good at what they were doing and the
people that were sticking with the good
numbers on anything that you picked up
there out of interest that you saw yeah
you know what I think a real difference
is between people that are doing good
numbers and people that are doing great
numbers is that sort of Drive that
doesn't die that doesn't drop out I
think that it's really easy to be super
focused and into your job for a month
three months yeah and then you're like
start cutting corners and you don't
screen you can that's proper way and you
don't interview the proper way and you
don't get feedback properly and you just
because of that your ratios drop and
then you try and put more balls in the
air and it just all falls apart the ones
that do seriously good numbers are the
ones that are completely methodical with
every process and yeah I'm really take
the time and get to know people and
treat everyone but like this job hunt is
important for that individual rather
than rushing through it yeah and you
know there are people that sort of have
a high amount of activity and not very
much quality that do good numbers but I
think the ones that do great numbers are
the ones that I'm really methodical and
knowing is anyone needs to be doing and
I'm willing to do on a daily basis yeah
or they work on a really great desk and
they do contract that's that's the
alternative isn't it I work a sector
that's like really buoyant that everyone
wants to spend money in get lucky land
on a contract desk build it or ideally
inherit some contractors and yeah and
why doesn't I say few things before we
gone to the harm piece and like I was
really keen to get you your sort of
experience this and force on this a
light fine I'm listening right now and
I'm at that sort of Year mark a
smart free is mark whatever but I'm that
sort of bit of a crossroads where maybe
I have pushed foot progression within my
business or I'm not too sure if my
future is within the agency I'm
currently in because it's like you know
what I think I'm solve outgrowing this
place whatever it may be like what and
that these people can be getting
absolutely peppered by rectorrocks2 no I
mean like messaged on a daily basis so
what what what the things that people
need to look out for you know I mean
when they're when they're when they're
like you know what I might actually be
open to looking elsewhere firstly how do
they sport a [ __ ] rhetoric mates you
know I mean yeah because like they don't
have the best reputation like recruits
didn't have a great reputation rhetoric
don't have a great reputation at a
weaver so like if on note that about 100
percent rates rates are value like
definitely how if I'm getting like hit
up and there's like three or four people
messing me all the time that it how do
you know I mean yeah what what kind of
disclaimer this from the start
really do rate certain rhetoric yeah
that some of my best mates a rector X so
and good rector X the ones that
genuinely understand the clients and
this is a misconception about Rex rep
that I'm sure will talk talk about soon
that a rect rect doesn't have to work
with every client out there and they
shouldn't work without with every client
out there when I was a wreck wreck I
work with a handful of clients that are
really liked if you see a rhetoric
posting on LinkedIn exciting opportunity
uncap Commission industry-leading
training which anyone that follows me on
LinkedIn sees that I ridicule these post
all the time I would just run a million
miles because they don't understand the
client at all yeah
there are wrecked wrecks out there that
post fantastic posts about what the
teams like what the coaches like what
where the manager comes from how the
manager recruits and why their clients
love them they're the ones you want to
be working with yeah so and I don't
think there's anything wrong with
working with a couple I think a lot of
people say I work with one exclusive
because they'll represent you the best
but if a rhetoric has got a really tight
client base who they want to work with
another rekt rekt might have a brilliant
relationship with another great
don't there's anything wrong with that
but just make sure they really know who
they're working with and they're not
gonna spam your CV out to everywhere
because someone will hire if you're a
recruiter and you're half decent you
walk into another job yeah walk into
another job yeah so just make sure they
know who the done that's really good
vice if you're getting hit up by anyone
at the moment and you're considering it
I actually take a look at their LinkedIn
profile what they're talking about if
they have message you or you've been on
the phone with them like how well do
they actually know their clients and
really measure them on that which I
think inserted right whenever I've done
work with retro X or spoke to Rex Rex
it's like I don't have a problem getting
clients hisham it's it's candidates and
these types of things but I think I
think that's a good point that it makes
sense that the best ones would yeah that
you don't need to what everyone dear so
you could you could even be saying you
could be like that this does sound like
an interesting opportunity that you've
tapped me up with and I am sort of
looking at the market I don't want to
know who your client is I know you're
not going to tell me that because you
worried I'll go direct and that's fair
enough
but can you just tell me something about
their hiring manager that I wouldn't
know from their website can you tell me
something about that culture that
wouldn't know that's a great question
yeah it's just something that you can
open up a conversation to prove that
they know what they're on that's really
good advice I think and okay staying on
this then let's flip it okay what should
recruiters what are the just the stupid
[ __ ] recruiters do you know I mean when
they're looking for a job yeah like what
are the just the big nine eyes that the
people who are listening who are
considered a job just need to avoid if
that's lying about how much they build
you know I mean like what are just the
big nose which you've just maybe through
your process of getting better ended up
happening at the final interview stage
it comes out or whatever do you know
what are like the big it's one of the
things that people just need to stop
doing if you're if you're thinking about
and going is another recruitment job and
you've got a recruitment experience yeah
it's funny that you mentioned Billings
because that we talked about that so
much there I think
everyone sort of exaggerated s' the
Billings a little bit apart from you in
your first year unless you had a but
like if you are gonna sort of skew you
been
a bit make sure you can work that out
and like you know you know how it breaks
down so so so often you'll speak to a
contract or a temp recruiter and you'll
be like what did you bail and they'll
say a figure and you realize okay so how
many runners have you got out what's
your margin what's your margin at peak
and the figures just do not even come
close to adding on hmm and then I'm not
sure on my figures and you're like well
if you're a recruiter that can do 200
grand alert yeah like you say you are
you'll know your figures mm so if you're
gonna blog your figures know what you're
on about that's the first thing I'd say
yes um stop leaving jobs off you CV or
or stop making your LinkedIn different
to your CV because everyone can take a
dude company like you can go to a
company for three months and hate it and
it's not right you don't have to lie
about that that is fine
and I think that a lot of people would
respect that you go in okay I really
like to sound your company because it
sounds a million miles away from this
company that wasn't right for me so just
own that yeah I don't don't lie about
that don't feel like you need to lie
about it yeah so I really like that then
if you're gonna exaggerate your billions
actually know what the [ __ ] numbers
are yeah and then yeah that I opinion
obviously yes that makes sense okay and
and then on the other side then
obviously this would be part of your job
as a ret to reckon these types of things
but for those listening as well what
what sort of red flags that they red
flags that they should be looking out
for if they me a recruiting agency maybe
they've gone direct or whatever yeah
that you don't know you've ended up
talking about maybe if you've had
cameras who you work with the interview
elsewhere that you picked up on like if
I'm a recruit right now I'm interviewing
other places or I'm thinking about and I
meet people like what what the red flags
that come to mind for you if I was a
recruit of 18 months experience two
years want to progress my career that I
should be looking out for when I mean
agencies yeah cool so I'm obviously an
hunted we talk all the time about
different uniques different like unique
perks that companies offer and how to
find a company that's right for you the
first thing above everything else is
just check out how many staff they've
lost in the last 12 months mmm go on the
LinkedIn if you've got LinkedIn premium
just see if they've been growing if
they've been shrinking have they've been
losing staff
workers that's massive isn't would you
ask that question to answer interview
yeah I think so
how many how many how many like yeah how
many staff have you lost in the last
time man yeah I mean obviously you want
to frame it in a way the right way makes
you come across like you're interested
in the company rather than just yeah but
yeah if you like look I'm I'm really
trying to get a handle on on what you
like as a business yeah so you know
recent people that you've lost who are
they where have they gone why have you
lost them if they've lost them to a
direct competitor then sort of red flag
right that's another question about yeah
I know you got to think about how you
word it yeah so think about okay well
yeah check really check them out how
many people have got three months of
this agency online and and how many
people they've got these sorts of things
you know for now so are they there no so
I have a look at sort of that attrition
rate how many staff they've got I'd look
at and how well they progress internally
I think he's important one I think are
they promoting people from within
they bring in senior people then above
people that are already there
hmm you don't want to get trapped in a
situation where you can't progress
hmm I'd have a look at what the clients
are saying about them in the market if
you can find that out anywhere you know
if you go on to Google reviews you can
see what clients or candidates are
saying about you um it's just really
easy isn't it to say in an interview I
was so great with the best of this with
the best at that where you want to be
finding out the truth from the people
that are on the front line the people
that are there doing the recruitment if
you can interview people that are in the
business that's great like get a handle
on what they're like just like to see if
a telling the truth and also from a
culture point of view you know is that
the sort of culture you want to be those
sort of people you want to be surrounded
by yeah cuz they make it don't they yeah
who you're surrounded by makes it that's
that's all of them would you clear that
so important and like would you
encourage people to like try meet as
many people within the other night like
what does that look like typically and
it what's the typical thing leave
experience whereas a lot R of they'll
meet the owner then I meet like the two
lie managers odd obviously depends on
the position but how how would you best
advise people to release or soak up the
culture besides
so I'm a big fan of going out for beers
after get an offer go out for a beer
with them and just don't go out for a
session with them now is that always
ends badly and you know someone ends up
in tears bought go out for a beer with
them or a couple of beers with them chat
to them about what they talk about in
the office chapter about you know what
they get up to even where they take you
for beers is it is a signpost about what
sort of company they are yeah if it
takes through it if they take you to a
spoonie's there one sort of company of
the tape - yeah absolutely
so just see what see what they're about
and I wouldn't - one company over
another because one company didn't
invite me out for beers really yeah and
and I mean I talked candidly this was it
this was an econ and my billions weren't
great he come I met some fantastic
people and got some lifelong friends
from there but I think billons wise had
done far better if I'd have gone to the
other place really and I made a call off
who'd invited me out for beers and why
did you make of that because I was like
that that shows they want me that shows
they want me to meet the team and now I
actually thought I just moved to London
so the team hadn't taken me out for
beers and ice like well maybe they don't
go out for beers maybe that's a thing
and didn't really know many people in
London didn't really have many that was
important to you to get the social
aspect whoever you were yeah that's fair
enough so I made that call and yeah
billions wise it wasn't fantastic for me
well you know how did you build money I
can't remember it was it more or less in
24k Shh less it was less yeah yeah it
was laughs it was that and like that's a
bit weird innit cuz just to be clear
anyone listening to this is gonna be
like why am i listening to this fool
he's he's clearly not very good at
recruitment this was a sector that I was
just not very good at so why why did you
join hunted because when I was doing
reps wrecking Manchester mm I saw them
post on LinkedIn and they were funnier
than me and they sort of got it they got
what I didn't know when I was
in rhetoric in Manchester that what I
was trying to do was talk about Brandon
and like how businesses should think
about their Brandon but that's what I
was talking about and then whom to come
along and all they do is talk about
Brandon's and how important Brandon is
and it's vital that every company
understands what they stand for and
really drives at home and I just
completely bought it completely bought
it really and then I met with James I
would just completely bought him as well
yeah and yeah I just just went with it
just just completely and I just want I
wanted to work there and I reached out
to James and I was I look mate I want to
work for you what is there an
opportunity I'm reading one work for you
and we had sort of had a bit of a
back-and-forth and then that found a way
to make it work and okay so then
obviously now it's obviously worked and
Rexroat for two years then did agency
mum yeah bit of a flop yeah and then
also join hunter for the last two years
obviously you you've I guess a bit like
me really where you've ended up with a
really sort of unique perspective on the
recruitment industry yeah is like a big
reason why I started this and remember
obviously it's become obviously a lot
more easier now but when I was in this
small office in a recruitment business
outside the London there was a of us
like it can feel like is just like you
like you guys just trying to make sure
happen and it typically it hasn't been
an industry where people are willing to
share sort of their challenges ideas and
these types of things so I think but
however you've you've got four years
experience of actually looking from an
outside into the recruitment industry
and that's obviously what what I'm
getting access to now so I think I'll
see you all and that you've been in a
really cool position too and look at
people as employer brands and how
recruit milites communicate what they
stand for and these types of things so
so well positions talk about that right
and be passionate about it for sure
so I guess obviously there's so much
that goes into this but like let's just
start with like what why our recruitment
is so bad at hiring for themselves is
actually like the craziest thing yeah
it's mad it's actually mental because
like if you think some of the most
successful recruitment businesses how
much money they're charging how much
value they bring to their clients and
candidates and they're just absolutely
shy to
for themselves yeah it's maddening it's
crazy and the very say let's start with
that yeah it's a massive question that's
what I mean but like let's you start
with that and see where that goes
because it's interesting isn't it like
and there'll be a lot of people
listening that are hiring for their team
and it is difficult and these types of
things as Losey we can talk about but
like let's just start there like why why
not be why are they so bad cool so I
think um as a starting point mmm
recruitment businesses don't know what
they stand for mmm and they don't know
who they're looking for to work for them
yeah so when you say stand for what do
you mean so they don't know what their
identity is more okay so a lot of
recruitment businesses think it's
acceptable to be a little bit better
than [ __ ] okay
so you speak to a recruitment agency and
you say what your USPS
and they say we're not KP eyed we're
autonomous and we want to sort of people
that have worked for Michael page and
they want somewhere with a little bit
more flexibility okay what you've told
me that is you tell me what you're not
you've told me that you're not Michael
pay mmm everything you've position there
is what you're aspiring not to be tell
me what you are mmm mmm say in no other
industry would you would you have that
way of selling anything you wouldn't
like buy a pair of trainers adidas
wouldn't sell their trainers has been
we're not like they would be we are
added an Australia so what are you not
what are you not and it's really
difficult and I think a lot of
recruitment businesses alike well
actually if we're being honest with one
another we're the same as everyone else
out there and you're not there
absolutely not
recruitment business every recruitment
business is different and I'm so
passionate about this and I get so angry
because recruitment businesses are so
crap at same what makes them unique and
we talk to hundreds of recruitment
businesses every week about really
digging down what makes them unique
versus everyone else and that is so
important as a difficult thing to do
though isn't it yeah and it figure out
it's not easy I mean it's not easy
button but there are a constant themes
that you can you can you can look at and
do you know what I think a lot of it
stems from the
so idea that you know KPI is a dirty
word and the idea of being like
somewhere where you have to get on the
phone and B D is seen as a negative
thing and like long hours or no like we
can't do long hours in recruitment
because it's seen as a negative thing
businesses need to own what they stand
for where they are and there are
companies out there who are really
old-school like smash the phone yeah and
work long hours and the recruiters are
making a lot of money and they're doing
a good job and because I don't think
this is any less valuable for the
recruitment industry because I think
that you know you're putting people into
jobs that they are enjoying and they're
staying there and they're and they're
enjoying what you how you've helped them
so that's a great thing definitely but
they then go when they advertise
themselves it's like flexible working
and like no case can't be something
they're not
and yeah they're not that own it say
like you know what we want we want
someone to come in here and smash the
phone but I guarantee you'll make more
money here through our management style
or leadership or training then you will
anywhere else hmm but instead they don't
and they say something really weak and
and it and it really frustrates me
because there are some seriously good
agencies out there that are just not
framing things in the right way and I
really want to help them but then um
yeah it's just quite difficult
conversations laughter um what do you
think so you said they're all real
criminals whose are different yeah what
do you think makes them different cuz a
lot of light you know I mean cuz I
should make some different you know from
your perspective do you think um a lot
of its culture the people you've got on
your team you know people so you pull it
back and you say okay so we have
candidates we have clients and we have a
weird little process in the middle that
marries up with - and that's our job
once that's everyone's job and
recruitment well that weird little
process in the middle we could put
everyone in the same room all the same
companies with the same clients and the
same candidates and that process would
be way different and the people that are
doing it be way different and you know I
you could even have you know certain two
sets of companies they've got to make
the same amount of call times and the
calls would be completely different yeah
who they'd be calling it'd be completely
different than fair and it's like are
you gonna janitor in a company that goes
finds a load of candidates gets to know
the candidates really well really invest
some serious amount of time into those
candidates gets to know the market
really well they give you leads on who's
hiring who's leaving who's on the market
all you want to go and attack your
clients eyes you want to go and find
clients first go and really win some
clients get to know him get to know what
makes him tick
really understand them better than
anyone any other recruiter out there
both of them have done serious amount of
cool times there but two completely
different styles yeah appealing to two
very different recruiters but I bet you
know company thinks about that when
they're thinking about their who they're
trying to hire no one goes to that
degree and that you should be going to
that degree mmm how should it should how
how do you think people should start if
yeah like if I'm in that sort of
position right now and yeah I'm a bit
like yeah like I'm just talking about
things which I think people want to hear
and I'm not owning sort of what we're
about there well it's like how do you
think from your opinion how do you think
people should start communicating
we just said they're like they're people
account Church you know yeah how how
come people start doing that what like
how can they find that out for
themselves with work and were like let's
say let's say that they they they make
some real time to think about it and
they're like you know what you know what
Joe you're speaking a lot of sense like
we need to own what we're about here
yeah thanks obviously besides going on
hunted like how like how can someone
start because that can seem quite
daunting conduct you know I mean yeah
what's your view on like how can someone
start communicating what they're about
and really owning what their culture is
and and the value that they bring and
how they approach things like what would
you say to people who like you know what
job I really get what you're saying how
can I start then how can I stop
communicating this so what did your
faults been I mean the first thing you
got to do is go to your staff and
actually make sure that what you
communicating is right because I think
so often things are implemented top-down
without actually going and clinics and
composite recruiters that are actually
doing it because the Kritters themselves
the ones that are all the team your
whole team and the ones that are
creating that culture
mmm they're the ones that are making
that culture of your business so you've
got to consult them but then after that
I mean it's a word that you love to talk
about and it's completely right when you
it all comes down to Brandon from
it's all brand new and that's everything
that's that's every touchpoint you might
have with a potential person joining
your business from content you're
putting on the internet on LinkedIn the
way that you write in job ads you
sponsor an events what events are you
sponsoring are you meeting with people
where you're meeting with people how are
you meeting with people where you're
interviewing people like what is your
interview process everything is a touch
point and everything can be used to
convey sort of what you stand for hear
about and that's that's everything
that's your office that you work in
that's where you go for a drink on a on
a Thursday or Friday that's all what you
what you stand for and all these things
are important to get across so I mean
obviously working for hunted a big thing
for us is sort of digital and digital
presence and how you can get that
message across because that's the
easiest way to convey to so many people
hmm
but just the tone you use I mean what
was trained in hearing to actually is we
could stray really quickly and easily
into personal branding there as well but
as a business who's representing you how
are they representing you and what are
they saying yeah I think for me I think
like just the biggest asset that hiring
managers have teams have recruitment
business is the stories and the people
in that and that business isn't that
yeah it just is and I think for me it's
yeah for me I think it's just showcasing
that and owning the stories within your
falls and being willing to champion
champion the staff within your business
and these are all things that a lot of
people already do within their four
walls if it's making sure that when it's
someone's birthday they get a birthday
cake or like just as simple as that but
actually like showcasing that online
it's just so important because as you
all know Joe there's so many agencies
online that they just don't they do look
the same and they don't look human and
yeah what's going on there fools is just
really not evident outside of that
yeah soon I think well you know I think
people fall and sort of sort of victim
to is that they write to recruiters in
the same way that they write to their
clients hmm so if you're or finance
recruitment agency and you're quite
corporate to the exterior I bet
good money that when you go out for
drinks on a Thursday your recruiters are
not stood there prim and proper at the
Allied speaking in corporate language
that completely down-to-earth people who
wrote for a laugh yeah they're the
people that you're trying to attract and
now the people that want to join you so
talk to them like that but your choice
of the words stories they're it's really
interesting actually I never thought
about it like that but we talked about
quite a lot in the office don't talk
about the what not what you are it's how
or why so what I'm award-winning we're
an award-winning company yeah well how
are you award-winning yeah what have you
won and why have you won it so we won a
certain award because all of our clients
said that we were great okay that's
superb why did you client say you were
great
oh because actually our retention with
everyone that we've placed there is 97
percent okay great why shouldn't
retention nice and percent yeah
and you like I was listening to someone
the other day that was talking about
five why's that if you ask why file a
Simon I know it wasn't something that
that's not simon Sinek is it I don't
know number Affairs but five why's yes
keep digging down yeah and we talk about
that all the time so um you know if
you're if if you say oh we're we're a
great place to work and people love
coming to work here give me a quote
let's let me hear from someone that
works out films they come on YouTube and
say yeah this is why Tony Lords come
into work and this is what he has to say
about it yeah and let's see you these
people are just really interesting it's
just funny though when those types of
people feel like they've got a gun point
then people try and but people try man
and maybe it comes across a bit stiff in
that it's still so important that
they're trying and trying to showcase it
I think that is still fair playing it
that people try that but sometimes yeah
fair enough and I think that I think
that um having an identity is everything
everything and there are plenty
recruitment businesses out there that I
don't I wouldn't want to work that not
my not my style of doing recruitment but
fair play to them for having an identity
and there and there are people that want
to work there they hire staff far more
easily than those that don't have an
identity and it and I just really want
there's some superb recruitment
businesses out there who have
insane perks and they just don't know
how to articulate them mmm yeah when you
say part what do you mean um something
that they offer that goes above and
beyond your salary and your holidays and
your basic package that you get mmm and
I think people you can talk about perk
is in you know flexible working or
amazing commission or perks as well
could also I think be like your culture
and the fact that actually someone
sitting three seats down from you just
pull the lead that they know that you
can work better than them and they've
passed it over to you yeah and that's a
perk because you gain a little bit of
support there from your business yeah
there's a perk as well best perk that
you've seen mmm for me
mmm I see individuals every one the best
things that you've seen that people are
showered about I mean a lot of
businesses are not a lot business some
of the minute they're talking about
recruiters working one day a week from
home which is great for some people I
will not work with mine I wouldn't know
it because I love the buzz of the office
and I need to be around people yeah I
love that it has a good part though for
people that's right Pete right yeah and
it's people different circumstances
aren't they you know if you want
flexible working and you know there's a
reason for that and you need to be
somewhere at certain time then great
that's that's what's most important to
you hmm
if you want to have the best commission
structure then I think that's going to
be a very different business person yeah
because it's trying to incentivize a
different sort person mm-hmm anything
else that you say maybe James and guy
could give us a free gym that'd be
decently they pay for my gym membership
every time is a great perk yeah I think
that's that's great oh no it's no actual
age you know I love about hunted um we
partner with little plug here and we
partner with Sanctus who are okay a
mental health charity yeah and we every
month we have a mental health catch-up
thing and it's fantastic con shout about
them and often really think that autumn
yeah that's wicked laughing that's
amazing
West Park
the moment someone writes uncap
commission on perk I it drives me insane
why the road it drives me and say why
tell me when you've ever seen a capped
Commission structure once I've never
seen I am it's not how do we use that
word it's the most pointless word in
recruitment uncapped oh yeah I'm sorry
I've done I've done 40 grand this this
this month oh yeah we're gonna cap it at
20 no you're not absolutely no way you
are stopping that person owed you know
I've done 20 grand this month I'm not
gonna bother Dean anymore cuz I'm not
gonna get any more money it just does
not happen yeah free fruit is pointless
as well a banana is what 15 P right free
free come on yeah okay and I know you
mean what out of interest them what are
like some of the rule common mistakes
that you've seen hiring managers mate
maybe about your rates rate days but
like or like wherever you sitting a lot
of common mistakes where you know you're
talking about owning it and it's all the
different touch points and these sorts
of things you know I mean whereas work
what are some of the sort of common
touch points that you've noticed that
people of maybe much hop on quite a lot
of times and these sort of things where
people get it get it wrong well it's not
quite an easy thing to show me some
people may not notice that when they sit
them down in the particular place it's
like that kind of in tells you Joe they
sat me down this place it was really
weird as orrible I don't don't get me
another interview there did you know I
mean is it any common sort of mistakes
that you've picked up on maybe so I
think that and because hiring managers
know that recruitment recruiters are so
in demand they sort of do a big sale on
what the business is mmm and again they
go back to doing this sort of generic
generic salon on what makes them great
but you've got to find out what makes
that individual tick first no way so
easy for when I'm when I first moved to
London
nice-nice of the beer on the go for you
there but he um when I first moved to
London I interviewed at this company
that I thought was great so I was having
a look at different things into this
company and on my first agents view all
they did was talk at me and I remember I
said about five words this whole
interview really I was like you know
nothing about me they said we're
desperate to get you back in we'd love
to would love to see you again
right now I don't I don't really want to
come back in from being on it's really
interests them so we I mean people want
to people want to feel wanted don't they
mmm everyone wants to feel wanted in the
next job won't you've got to get to know
them so that's so key I guess that's a
really important point to remember that
obviously you have to it's both ways
isn't that kinda has to sell themselves
and they have to sell their company but
if it is just if I'm a hiring manager
right now and I'm in an interview and
I'm just selling theirs pounding it into
Joe like this is why we're great this is
why we're great yeah and you said like
few words yeah that isn't gonna get you
excited it no no that's a really
important point because it's easier to
do that because it's like as you know
it's before I've got a real crew in
front of me is about 18 months
experience he's pretty decent yeah I'm
gonna get a job
yeah do you know I mean it's like a
hiring manager is gonna be like right
okay he's definitely gonna be
interviewing it yeah I need to sell him
hard here do you know I mean yeah that's
that must be a time I sense yeah and
then on the flip one of my favorite
clients I've ever worked with I think
they're fantastic business they've got a
really interesting offering RPO business
so a lot of recruiters want to work
there they were taking like six weeks to
do a recruitment process so they're
doing three stages really and then I
meet the director or something daft and
because it was RPO and you know there's
a lot of people that want to move away
from agency into RPO people were
sticking with the process for quite a
long time and then like week four just
going like now I've had enough of this
this isn't for me if this is how you run
an interview process like I can't
imagine and what would be like to work
here really so just getting a bit of a
shifty on you know that there is I don't
think there is any need in recruitment
to do more than like a two-stage process
and I meet the team yeah
the rest is pretty solid you know meet
him for an hour have a really informal
chat meet him a second time maybe grill
him a bit harder maybe ask him to do a
presentation if they're a bit more
senior meet the team as well get the
team's input on him you've got a pretty
good handle there yeah are they a good
culture fit are they gonna bill well do
they hold the same values as you you
should know if you're gonna hire them or
not at that point how should people sell
recruitment how do they sell recruitment
how how do you think people should sell
recruitment
so how do you think people should sell
recruitment I don't know how to answer
that really like okay so here's why go
on you know your event last week yeah
which was fantastic anyone who missed it
but he won yeah I there was quite a long
conversation around recruiters should be
adding value first and making postman
second yeah really interesting point
yeah love it I think it's a really good
conversation we need to have the issue
is our clients are paying us for making
placements not for adding value yeah
well unless you work in a different type
of model I'm talking about pure agency
sort in gingers which is great but
adding value it is only going to keep
the lights on for so long before you
need to make a placement and I think we
need to have a conversation about how we
can be adding value which is something
that haunted do and plug for haunted
that we do more than just make
placements but we need to be having a
conversation about sort of monetizing
adding value otherwise we're going to
we're not going to last you know so I
think that adding value goes
hand-in-hand with making placements you
can make placements that add value to a
person's career and you can add value to
someone's career which then results in
them later down the line coming back to
you for the next placement hmm but we've
got to remember that in a contingent
basis you only get a fee when you make a
placement so it's got to be in some way
still a sales job do you think this came
up with the event as well like it like I
work contingent how how long do you
think that lanced they'll always be a
place for it yeah I think they will
because a good business will recognize
if you've got someone of value yeah that
something that added value to the
business then yeah let's talk about
continuum wreck to wreck if I and we're
if I was a contingent rector at working
with a candidate who I knew was going to
do ten grand the month that's what
they've always said they've done more
than that fifteen grand the month so
let's say they're going to do ten grand
a month they're going to put 120 Karen
your bottom line over the next 12 months
and I'm asking you to pay me six grand
for them
and I mean the economics of that work
out really well don't they you know
that's great that every party isn't it
so that's gonna always be there I love
all these em embedded companies that
come an hour and I think a lot of
businesses are having a conversation and
bound about embedded solutions and even
like pure contingent agencies are
talking to me about it asking me sort of
thoughts on their solutions yeah and I
think a lot of recruiters are attracted
to it because you can really add value
to a client mmm but I do think that
contingent you know there's there's a
value in a good person joining your
business yeah so someone's always going
to take nice autre of interest yeah how
how different do you think they're so
typical recruiter is today than it was
when you was starting out in Manchester
and like tapping up people and stuff
like do you think this sort of recruiter
back there and they'll see what that's
what four years ago yeah four and a half
years ago and a half years ago yeah how
different do you think that typical
recruiter was then compared to where we
are now hmm I think there's a difference
the interesting thing what you said
there was in Manchester and there is
still a huge difference between London
as a market and the various different
regional cities as a market yeah I'm
just I'm certain that there are certain
businesses that you speak to in certain
locations and they just are not in any
way interested in embracing the idea of
branding or marketing even for
themselves to their own clients yeah and
it baffles me because you know you're
doing all your business off
word-of-mouth which is is he's gonna run
its course at some point when good good
businesses can promote themselves
through marketing
you're gonna lose out to them mmm so I'd
say there is quite a difference I think
that people now are talking far more
about flexible working I think they're
talking more far more about sort of
genuine progression and development that
is bespoke to them and having training
that's bespoke to them and but I also
think there's a massive divide between
London
and all the cities in how we go about
approaching recruitment hmm and I'm not
saying one's better than the other yeah
doesn't well my next question okay
Manchester of London I'm in Manchester's
my home I mean it's not snow contract
but Manchester's my spirit home it's
like I really I love that place really
best city in the world so good decent
light Linda's decent yeah
but like um yeah Manchester mate no I
really like Manchester really like it
okay mate so Joe and even recruitment
yeah people get all the way through and
then the like cut what I'm not gonna
listen to now yeah I'm leaving
recruitment main we don't I'm off to
become a police officer with the Met
Police as mad yeah yeah bit of a change
wreck Trek to a copper both both not got
the best reputations out there in the
market yeah I am and this is why I was
really keen to come on because I don't
what I don't want people to think is me
think is me coming on and being like
spiteful and slating recruitment because
you know I absolutely love this industry
I do I think it's a mental industry
that's mad and I think we need to M
address and a part of the fact that
there are a lot of people that come into
it and do a few months and then leave
yeah and that is always gonna be the
case because it's not right for everyone
but I really wanted to come on and just
try and start a conversation about for
certain recruitment businesses out there
that are struggling to hire and a-goin
the structure looks real but she's not
helping me this job boards not working
and saying look there is other ways we
can do this we can help you hire and you
are a great business you're gonna find
staff you just need to change your
outlook on it I just wanted to do that
before I left recruitment altogether
yeah this is the place to do it mate so
if interest in if you're obviously
leaving recruitment becoming a police
police officer yeah that right police
officer yeah please policeman police
officer
a few adsorbs yes so was your gonna go
into that and let's say like you did not
hear anything about recruitment for five
years yeah and then but if you were to
like just dip back in five years from
now what would you like to see of the
agency would you how would you have
liked to see things evolve or how John I
mean what would you what would you love
to see change hmm I would like to see
more companies working either retained
or exclusive hmm I would like to see um
a little sort of the embedded model grow
bought with recruiters within that
recognizing that embedded is very
different to internal it's a very
different proposition I would like to
see the contingent contingent agencies
that remain sort of I would say remain
this you know it's not like they're
going to go under in five years is it
then you know it's gonna only grow and
grow like the other contingent agencies
either way recruiting recognizing that
you can't just spam a CV and hope for
the best you've got to add real value I
think Tony said was it Tony that said
that you're a yes or what one of the
questions which it was from James
actually I thought it's a great question
like I said there's so many agencies
still working old school like what habit
would you love to see died out yeah
that's such a good question
yeah isn't and he said that and he
nailed it you know it's not good enough
to just spam a CV over now and yes
really not so I'd love to see that it
sort of grows up and matures into
recognizing that it's about
relationships and yet don't get me wrong
there's a time for going picking up a
phone and dial in a hiring manager or an
internal recruiter and saying they've
got this person from what I know about
your business I think they'd be great
mmm bought that from what I know about
your business is important because that
shows you know something about them
rather than just plugging it yeah if you
ever come back to recruitment
I'm gonna hope not otherwise yeah
although I'm making a really bad career
move now and it's wasting yeah fair
enough me maybe who knows who knows
before we finish me yeah so what were
you always ask people what they're
excited about I guess for you just yeah
pick on the policeman
yeah and plug otherwise James of slam
arrest
yeah before I leave I'm excited that
hunted is absolutely going from strength
to strength and all the things we talked
about the reason of love working here is
that they are at the forefront of hone
those combat absolutely but not not plug
too hard because I know it's boring to
listen to him last question yeah if if
he could communicate to every recruiter
out there and they'd listen to Joe yeah
there could be a word of phrase what do
you say to them what a phrase
yeah like slight they'd implement your
advice they take it on it could be a
phrase could be a word what comes to
mind if for all the recruiters out there
would listen and take on an advice what
would you say to them know what makes
you unique know what makes you unique
and I mean that as a business and I mean
that personally and who was he talking
about at your event but like standing
out from the rest
yeah knowing your market knowing what
makes people tick
building up a solid candidate list
people that really trust you that you
add value to yeah solid client list
owning your market and just like not
taking yourself too seriously have a bit
of fun with it you have a bit of fun
with it you know someone sorry I'm
rambling on but case in point um
internal no not internal recruiter
marketing director had a market in
format Burton associates ok RPO in
Warrington I want to say right off my
head alright
all he does is post a things that things
all day on LinkedIn that is completely
himself thousands of likes they get and
he said at a LinkedIn event the amount
of people that reach out to him wanting
to work for my bonus oh she 'it's
because he represents their brand they
think that he is what they stands
and he owns it and they do so well
because of it yeah any post are things
you know might win it dank house all you
can name all that all these people that
post stupid things get serious traction
that's that's what we want to see isn't
it yeah so know what makes you unique
and just don't be too serious just be
the pleasure mate thanks May enjoyed
that Thanks